travail le mérite ce qui leur
(bips)
- Le salaire minimum devrait-il
passer à 20 $ de l'heure?
- Je crois que c'est une bonne
idée, si ça permet que les gens
peuvent avoir un salaire...
"vivable".
- Le client va être obligé
de payer bien plus cher
pour son hamburger.
- C'est un des plus importants
hommes d'affaires du Québec
qui a relancé le débat.
LOUIS AUDET, prés., conseil
d'administration de Cogeco
- En France avec les gilets
jaunes, au Royaume-Uni avec
le Brexit, quand les gens en ont
assez, il arrive des choses
qui... on perd la cohésion
sociale. Et quand la cohésion
sociale est brisée,
la démocratie peut être mise
à mal. Alors, c'était le point
de départ de ma réflexion.
- Une sortie remarquée
qui a justement fait réagir
le ministre des Finances.
ERIC GIRARD, ministre
des Finances, Québec
- Justement, pour éviter
ce débat discrétionnaire,
à chaque printemps, on a mis
une règle : 50 % du salaire
horaire moyen. Et sur la base
de ce que je vois cette année,
il y aura une augmentation
importante du salaire minimum.
- Depuis le 1er mai dernier,
le plancher salarial est
à 13,50 $ de l'heure.
Les syndicats réclament depuis
un moment un salaire minimum à
18 $ en raison de l'augmentation
du coût de la vie.
DENIS BOLDUC,
secrétaire général, FTQ
- Nous, on dit : le minimum,
c'est 18 $ de l'heure,
alors qu'un patron, aujourd'hui,
vienne nous dire : ça prendrait
20 $ de l'heure pour aplanir
les inégalités sociales, nous,
on peut pas faire autrement
qu'applaudir.
- Mais la Fédération canadienne
de l'entreprise indépendante
prévient qu'une telle
augmentation pourrait faire
très mal aux PME.
FRANÇOIS VINCENT, v.-p. Qc,
Féd. entreprise indépendante
- Il y a 53 % des PME qui n'ont
pas retrouvé leurs revenus
normaux "dû" à la pandémie.
Augmenter une des principales
charges de la petite entreprise,
qui est le salaire des employés,
de 48 %, ça ferait extrêmement
mal aux petites entreprises.
- Le Conseil du patronat croit
que le débat doit avoir lieu,
mais souligne du même souffle
qu'il y a déjà une pression
à la hausse sur les salaires.
KARL BLACKBURN, président,
Conseil du patronat du Québec
- On parle aujourd'hui de plus
de 220 000 postes de disponibles
actuellement qui viennent
freiner notre relance
économique. Il y a déjà
une pression à la hausse
sur les salaires dans tous
les secteurs d'activités.
- Augmenter le salaire
de base tout en gardant
les entreprises compétitives,
le débat est lancé.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, M